as for the coronavirus nationally
hospitalizations are rising in 37 states
governors of new york new jersey and
pennsylvania are asking people not to
travel
between those states to stop the spread
and in the state of wisconsin where
cases are surging
many hospitals are approaching capacity
rural states now lead the country in per
capita covet hospitalizations
in at least four midwestern states and
alarming 20 percent of recent tests are
positive
the cdc says it is safe to open things
up when that number
is below five percent i feel like we're
at the limits of
overwhelming the health system right now
she had a reinfection of covid
she had it a month ago and now again
over the last week the country has
averaged about 59 000 new cases a day
that number is expected to soon surpass
more than 75 thousand and top a record
that was set back in july
so brian here's a look now at cases in
our state more than 650
new cases have been reported since
monday the total now has surpassed 91
thousand
and 15 more people died 13 deaths being
reported here in southern nevada
and cases locally are up more than 400
to nearly 76 thousand
hospitalizations and ventilators in use
are also up
but icu patients are down